Ukraine's first lady zelinska and
European parliamentary president Roberta
matsola spoke on a panel Saturday about
sexual violence being committed by
Russian troops in Ukraine
the aggressors that have started a war
on our continent will not go unpunished
I am the mother of four Sons I would
like to be able to tell them
when Ukraine wins the war that everybody
will be held accountable for the crimes
that they have committed and the
atrocities that we have seen committed
against the brave ukrainians
said that Ukraine's Prosecutor Office
was investigating
171 cases of sexual violence committed
by Russian troops in Ukraine she added
that those were only the official
numbers speculating that we do not know
how many suffer in silence especially in
the occupied territories Ukraine is
hosting the United for Justice
Conference on war crimes seeking to
bring together International Partners to
establish a war crimes Tribunal for
Russia and its leadership